congratulations a very difficult game
you really had to work for uh the full
point and you know last year wasn't such
an easy start for you at the Juniors but
definitely it felt like you came
determined in this tournament yes I the
the thing with this tournament is
whether you come second or you're
content there's just there's no
difference at all like from my point of
view right you want to win it yeah
absolutely well let's talk about your
first round game and again not an easy
opponent definitely you chose this
variation but it felt like he sort of
surprised you with this bishop to D7
yeah Bishop D7 I don't remember him
having any games on this but I think
that this position like it seems of
course like it everything is like very
very close to draw but it feels that
like when I have obstacle Bishops and if
I ever get e45 like in the game I have
some very serious winning chances but of
course there should be some way not to
allow this e45 you mean Indiana game yes
yes because yeah he here I think this
Kinga feed is kind of inaccurate like a
couple moves ago yes
because here I think black should go
Rook like Rook B4 yes yes now the idea
is like if I go Rook A4 you can go like
Rook B3
okay and this is okay still close to
equal but I'd still prefer white right
because the thing is whenever I whenever
you take on C1 I'm essentially up by a
pawn because a A and C pawns you're not
going to ever promote them in e45 like
like this is much more valuable makes
sense yeah Central uh majority and the
other good thing about White's position
is like of course it looks like you have
like all these terrible pieces on the
back rank but you have this neon Bishop
on C6 and Knight on C4 so despite the
limited material you are still feeling
quite comfortable with the position in
your advantage yes because I didn't see
a way for way for black to force a draw
and okay if you you have a game
but he defined it well he really
defended well and then yeah I think that
King E2 is also nice because
originally after uh this whole position
it if black ever gets F5 Knight F6 he's
fine like for example after Rook D2 like
if you went F5 this is the first thing I
was calculating just because if this
works then okay black goes Knight F6 and
he covers E4 well I can still try a bit
but it's nothing much but I think I have
King C3 and the point is now wherever
you move like room B8 and group D5 okay
that makes sense now like we should
before I go King C2 G6 I have Rook D7
okay he doesn't have enough time yeah
you cover everything he's just one move
away yeah
very nice so he played Rook ba now I
think yeah King E2 is a nice move
because if I go E4 if I go H3 you go
Rook d8 I was also the same game didn't
seem so clear to me because like okay E2
like take take Knight F6
and now here maybe King C3
uh King E7 B4 the point is I was asking
like you're trying to ask where this
bishop is going if Bishop D6 E4 you win
a piece so Bishop B6 go Bishop B6 and
now I thought this is probably a draw
but okay this bishop on B6 is kind of
stuck maybe I can try some G4 G5
somewhere but I think this king E2 is
much nicer because I get
control of the D file You're Still The
One having all the fun in the position
also what I think is what I think he
missed is Knight G4 Rook D2 this
position it looks uh sorry like a couple
moves ago
yes because here actually Bishop takes
E3 is a very
very critical line to calculate
but here because Knight TX Rook B3 is
fine so I go Rook
my plan was to go rokito now okay Bishop
C5 Checkmate and if he goes Knight of
two
like here King E3 brooksie for my twin
but just but now like Knight D1 Knight
G4 this is very very it doesn't it
doesn't work but what's important is I
have King C3 and okay everything
collapses very nice yeah he does he
doesn't have a way to define absolutely
everything and once again Bishop C5
rookie yeah very nice nice calculation
um but yeah at this point I felt like
this position must be completely winning
and yeah that's how uses it very nice so
okay that's confident but F5 is probably
too early like I was
there must be something better than this
because but I was worried that somewhere
if he goes 96 at the right time take on
E6 take on E6 then this power and F4
will get
let's see so it'll be thought of weak
because somewhere like E7 Bishop H2 so I
cannot really freely go Knight C7 King
C4 King V5 as I would want to go yeah
so you played F5 you felt but yeah that
was Bishop D4 and all of a sudden okay
now 98 at this position is actually
quite interesting like it black is
probably making a draw but what's
important is like if he goes Knight C7
this is what I was I spent like 15
minutes in this position after instead
of when I was playing C6 and that I
calculated this to be winning the whole
point is I want to keep my king on say
A6 B7 and then okay and but there's also
one important thing that if he ever goes
H5 King G8 King H7 like I think H5 I
should meet with H4 okay because if I
don't do this he gets this King to if he
takes on F6 it's a draw because if the
it's the h8 squares right wrong color
right so you have H4 King G8 say like
King C4 A6
King C5 so what if he goes King H7 now
you give him a check now you can try
King H6 and try some stalemate things
but okay King B5 even if you give up the
a pawn somehow I'm not I'm not going to
play C7 I'll just bring my king over to
E8 take off seven that makes sense very
nice very nice and the point with this
bishop on D7 is okay your king will
never come in the game yeah and I have
this zuk zwang with if black tries like
H6 for example
well like Knight C7 takes takes F6
I'm not sure how exactly you can make it
my turn but let's say H6 King C4 A6
I can go King C5
and what I'll keep repeating this
position if you have to go King G8
probably
and I thought maybe yeah I think before
working but okay that's he's not
necessarily forced to do that but yeah
Bishop d8 I can always win with King D5
so yeah maybe this is also working okay
okay and the other thing is I can also
try like Bishop 5 Bishop D3 because some
of these lines I have to
but you have to be very careful that's
A5 right so that you can start going
King B5 King A6 that makes a lot of
sense very nice uh calculation there and
yeah now this end game it's probably a
draw it's still a draw but it's it's
very easy
and I think this was the critical
mistake because the point is I forced
him to like I got this H4 at a very nice
moment because
uh H4 because if he had if you want H5 I
had Knight F4 and yeah I think it was
working out in my favor yeah and now
here all he needs is like all I need is
to bring my king on the E6 and game is
over like this bishop D2 Knight C5 I got
like if I get Knight to a 16 F7 it's
resignable because the issue is if you
keep Bishop on this A1 to H attack no I
go King G7 king of seven King G7 take H6
yeah if you keep issue on G5 I can go C7
King D6 kc6 yeah well not King C6 Bishop
F4 but I'll play King E7 I can even
bring my king to G7 and should be lost
and he played Bishop D2 after that you
got the Knight C5 King C4 I'll be honor
you congratulations big victory for you
your Ambitions are pretty clear for this
tournament we'll see you in the rest of
your games thank you
well done Mishra well done indeed and
let's uh just take a look